in the grim darkness of the far future
there is only war and for a war of such
unimaginable scale there must exist a
weapon of unparalleled fury and power to
act as the last line of defense against
humanity's doom a weapon wielded by
superhumans and forged in the fires of
over ten thousand years of battle the
Balkan from its humble beginnings
standing out amidst the iconic arms of
science fiction to its implementation
across both tabletop and video games
this particular weapon has had an
undeniable impact on pop culture so I've
come to Warhammer world to talk to the
very people that build that legacy and
created one of the most iconic weapons
in Warhammer 40,000 the bolt gun also
commonly referred to as the Balta is
most well known for being the primary
armament of the superhuman heroes of the
41st millennium the space marines it is
a weapon of devastating effect that's
brought to bear against the deadliest of
mankind's foes whether it be hulking
aliens warped touched demons or the
armored heretics Space Marine legions
the ball gun is a roaring weapon that
fires a massive 0.75 caliber two-stage
rocket propelled explosive bolt as
standard the bolts are comprised of a
diamond tine tip with a mass reactive
fuse and contains a depleted at D etre
iam call now that's a lot of cool sci-fi
made at words but all that you really
need to know is that it can penetrate
the thickest armor of enemy opposition
and detonate effectively blowing them up
from the inside out but in the world of
Warhammer 40000 the bolt gun was
designed by the god Emperor of mankind
and manufactured on huge forged planets
by the cybernetically enhanced tech
priests of the Adept aspec Anika's the
engineers technical servants and keepers
of humanity's most technologically
advanced hardware but in the real world
the holy balkan had much humbler
beginnings to truly understand the
history of the bog and however we need
to head to the source look at the sketch
creations and bizarre designs of jazz
Goodwin decades ago examine the
painstaking application of two thin
coats by Duncan Rhodes and the war
hammer TV team and seek out information
on the various other people that
contributed to the creation of the icon
weapon only then can we really get a
handle on its impact the original design
of the bolt gun was done by a guy called
Bob Naismith in the late eighties when
we were just starting out wrote trader
which was our first iteration of
Warhammer 40,000 I worked on the first
set but I tended to do things like I was
doing the helmets and various other
things
the ganondorf had been made to go on to
that and we worked around the gun but
what we found was that some of the
design features on there weren't really
conducive to having Marines running
around holding them the magazine was a
bit too far forward so he's other hand
was behind it when he was holding it
when we first did it
Rick who'd written for TK was looking at
some development had been going on on
gyro jet guns but the idea was that for
a big marine that you needed a big gun
and having machine gun didn't really
works and he what he wanted was this
thing that pumped out massive explosive
shells and so he wrote it up accordingly
to that I don't think he was necessarily
going this is what we would be using in
40,000 years time he just wanted
something really brutal this no doubt
helped what saw a new sci-fi franchise
stand out against Titans like Judge
Dredd Star Wars and The Terminator
we're all dominating the 80s with their
unique takes on futuristic fiction
during the 80s and 90s science fiction
was very much in love with using
brightly colored lasers as their weapon
of choice but the industrial futurist
form of the bolt gun a grim dark weapon
designed to fight the horrors of deep
space set it aside from the clean sleek
offerings they'd become a mainstay in
sci-fi I think it's got a lot to do with
the design even through the different
specifications of the bolter like the
heavy bolt or Bob pistols it's got
unique design features that you can
trace to each type and also you can
trace back through the history of
Warhammer 40,000 so you can look at a
primary smearing with a bolt rifle and
you could trace that back to Road trader
and that's the testament I think to the
studio's work in making something super
recognizable that has longevity it's
it's an iconic thing I don't think it
was conscious I think what happened was
that we made what we thought would work
with our
stop I'm certainly we made what would
work as a small toy soldier we weren't
thinking about a larger version or we
weren't thinking about how it would look
in the real world or a film prop this
was all about how it would work on a toy
soldier how would look on the tabletop I
think the ball Torreya Lee stands out
because it seems to be a slightly
unnecessarily brutal weapon it's a
really large machine gun that not only
shoots things but then the bullets
explode afterwards so if you need
something dead it will absolutely make
something dead the Godwin patent Volta
is currently the most widely used varied
of the weapon and has served the
superhuman servants of mankind for many
millennia the bolt gun is built with the
inhuman size of the space marines in
mind with their stature and power armor
being able to absorb the recoil that
would completely destroy the arm of any
average human but there are more compact
models of the bolter that exist for the
use of the unag mented defenders of the
domain of humanity such as the Godwin
Diaz Patton bolt gun is wielded by the
sisters of battle the sisterhood of
warriors that make up the fighting force
of the religious cult of the Imperium
and there's the smaller caliber ball
guns that were stowed to the unag meant
each human forces of mankind's army be
there and the leading hands of an
officer of the astra millet arm or as a
tool of discipline in the hands of a
commissar in the world of Warhammer
40,000 the enemies of mankind are
without end and as such the armaments of
the space marines must be able to
overcome any and all foes and while
cleaving chained swords superheated
plasma weapons and claws shrouded in
lightning certainly can get the job done
there are a few weapons that have the
reverence of the holy Volta beyond the
standard pattern of the weapon there
exists a plethora of other bought
weapons so a marine with a ball tomaybe
outnumbered but never outgunned they are
very much a weapon of their environment
a brutal weapon to perfectly match the
brutal way of life in the 41st
millennium so the bolts are in a way
summarizes the Imperial dogma and that's
a space marine way the space removes a
devise to be a spear pointer a thrust to
the heart and the bolt ER is the perfect
weapon to sum that up really this is
something that can even kill another
Space Marine if it's used well so we're
talking about a weapon here that is
built for power for anger for noise for
thunderous impacts for intimidation it's
really heavy it's quite temperamental
it's difficult to maintain
but it's worth it the Imperium considers
it worth it for the sheer amount of
force this thing can kick out one of the
things I was always first drawn to with
with spaceman's in particular is a lot
of the the most scariest of races and
things like that in sci-fi tend to be
some sort of alien and with a spaceman
you take off his helmet and it looks
human underneath his face or nerd I'll
be scarred up and bits missing Bionic
replacements here the holy weapon which
he deals death with is the bolt gun in
every spaceman army you're gonna have
you know dozens and dozens of bolt
weapons because it's it's how they wage
war you know they they destroy people
they blow bits up there's no such thing
as a glancing shot with a with a pop
weapon you're gonna lose something if
you get a direct hit Space Marines take
brutality to a whole new level whether
it's how they you know take on people in
combat or how they know you dead range
it's yeah it's all about the brutality
buddy well the bolter is a common sight
of the tabletop is also helped bring a
sense of power to some of my favorite
Warhammer videogames one of the first
games appeared in was 1992 space crusade
on systems like ms-dos Commodore 64 and
the ZX Spectrum considered to be a
faithful conversion of the original
board game it pitted a team of Space
Marines against an alien force and tatha
with clearing out a roaming mass of lost
spaceships that have been fused together
an entity known as a Space Hulk the
selection of Warhammer 40,000 games
would stick to the tactical and
strategic formula with chaos gate and
rights of war until 2003 when THQ and
Coogi Games released a first person
shooter offering in the form of fire
warrior this was the first time I
remember hearing the roar of a Volta and
really being taken aback by how fearsome
the weapon sounded especially when I saw
the Raptors chapter mowing down the
tower in the opening scene of fire
warrior I also had no idea that the game
featured the voice hunt of Brian Blessed
Peter Serafinowicz and Sean Pertwee
until I went back and played it for this
very video a year later we would see the
reveal of what is possibly the most
popular Warhammer 40,000 video game
series with a trailer that still gives
me goosebumps to this day
God of War would grace our pcs in 2004
but what was interesting about the
series was that across the three games
and the handful of expansions each title
felt different from the last
while the original Dawn of War was a
true and true RTS title that utilized
squads of Balta our Marines as the
default military unit barking shots from
cover dawn of war too instead focused on
the small squad combat and skirmishes of
the space marines allowing you to alter
the war gear of the unit's finding
different patterns of the bargain or
even legendary relic Baltar's to alter
your loadout through a game Dawn of War
3 however was a blend of both that built
on the heroic arms and abilities of its
characters while bringing back much of
the base building elements that were
popular from the first title personally
Dawn of War 2 is my favorite of the
series as it was a game that really made
Space Marines feel like Space Marines
all of the stories I had read in novels
and codex's always describe the might of
a space rain and the bark of a bolt gun
but Dawn of War 2 was a game where I
felt like the developers had finally
portrayed a Marine and his weapon in the
light it deserves and two years later
relic would take that feeling and dial
it up to 11 with what is my favorite
game in the Warhammer 40,000 universe in
2011 relic released Warhammer 40,000
Space Marine which has what I believe to
be the best virtual representation of a
Space Marine it put you in control of an
incredibly strong durable marine and you
just felt like a killing machine
the characters were how I imagined space
marines to act they looked exactly how
they were supposed to worry not captain
I've saved some orcs for you but most
importantly they absolutely nailed the
bolt-gun it was a weapon that would find
use in nearly every encounter whether
you were dispatching orcs or chaos it
always felt like the perfect weapon for
the job and it was oh so satisfying when
you watched your enemies burst apart
after a ball to him in my mind space
ring was the first game to really nail
the roar of the Bolton while it's hard
to imagine what sound such a
larger-than-life weapon would make when
you're reading the novels or playing the
tabletop as soon as I started putting
the trigger on my xbox 360 controller I
knew this was the best the Balta had
ever been from its muzzle flash to the
damage inflicted to the hiss and roar of
a round flying towards a green skin this
is the game I continued to hold all
other videogame Baltar's against 20 17s
Deathwing would see players return to
the foul xenos infested space hulks with
a storm bolt ax and assault cannon in
hand the co-op fantasy shooter offered
an experience similar to that of left 4
dead or the Warhammer Fantasy entry
vermintide it was a title that pitted
you against seemingly overwhelming odds
with an arsenal of customizable
equipment personally this is what makes
me feel like a Space Marine in one of
these games I want to feel those
overwhelming odds against success but
also that have the superior firepower
and strength to overcome them I want to
feel like the thundering bolt gun in my
hands is capable of dropping aliens
demons and armored behemoths alike being
powerful is something that many games
don't always get right but games like
death ring and Space Marine absolutely
nail it for my the one I like personally
the most I think is the one that was in
the fire warrior video game a number of
years ago and he finally picked the
weapon up it was almost like he took it
from an ended level boss so how do I
sort of mystique about it then when he
tried shooting it you could actually see
the rounds might pop out the gun and
then ignite and shoot my rockets it was
almost like a reward at that point
because he got load of Imperial
Guardsmen running up to and he if he
fired the secondary mode they would just
get blasted to pieces it was - and it
was it was horrific Lee violet of course
but that's exactly what they do there
they're really really disgusting new
powerful weapons and they're they're all
about representing the brute force of
how the Imperium fights with a weapon
that has the sheer power and reputation
of the ball gun it also has an
interesting problem when it comes to the
implementation on both the tabletop and
in video games it's important for a
gaming experience to be balanced but the
ball guns immense power presents a
unique problem for developers working on
both video games and the real world
tabletop game on the one hand you want
to create a tense and immersive game
that truly captures the essence of the
space marine experience but on the other
you don't want to cheapen that
experience by leaning too heavily on the
overpowered renowned and infamy of a
Space Marine and his bolt gun while many
novels and short stories do great work
when it comes
creating the experience of a marine and
their go-to armaments what makes for an
interesting story may not always make
for a tense and engaging gaming
experience I've seen some of the
boulders in video games they vary a huge
amount some of them have way too high
rate of fire one of some of them have
way too slower way to fire but it's it
is what it is it was a gun that was
actually designed for a toy soldier it
has to take some kind of modification
when you put it through other types of
medium-well Warhammer 40,000 Bolger may
not have the same renown or fame as some
science fiction franchises boast it is
certainly one of the most unique and
enduring firearms in the genre it's
something that's very distinctive to the
franchise but it's also a weapon that
newcomers to 40k can appreciate and
latch on to it was a weapon opted to
keep the bang in science fiction rather
than add to the orchestra of you and
it's a fictional firearm that perfectly
complements the very real grimdark genre
that Warhammer 40000 helped champion in
fact grimdark is a term that is derived
from the very tagline of Warhammer
40,000 the bolta says so much about the
world in which exists it's a brutal
weapon for a brutal universe wielded by
only the most ferocious it's a galaxy
inhabited by warring alien races
pestilent demon gods and the most foul
of mutants if you see or hear about the
Bolton your mind starts to dance with
the thoughts of what exactly a weapon of
such fury would be needed for what could
be so awful that a portable rocket
launcher with piercing exploding heads
wielded by superhumans is what's
required to kill it it's not clean it's
not shiny and it's not subtle but nor
should it be in fact I think this is one
of the reasons why it stood out in
science fiction the brutality of the
universe is reflected in the brutality
of its armaments I think the Balter says
something quite interesting about
Warhammer 40,000 because although it
does have laser weapons plasma weapons
like quite sort of high-concept sci-fi
weapons the Balter feels more medieval
because it's very physical and very
substantial and that to me conveys one
of the core aspects of Warhammer 40000
which is that kind of quasi fantasy
aesthetic so it's a key part of that it
feels like a representation of what the
Imperium Islay
they are beset on all sides they face
threats every day it's a very dire kind
of situation to be in and I think that
breeds a weapon like that
so the Balter is almost emblematic of
the in parents response to being
besieged constantly it's very much a
weapon that comes from the situation
that they are existing the space marines
it is something that's just become
iconic and it's so iconic that we can
actually change the size shape and a lot
of those things and people still know
what it is it's supposedly a
sophisticated weapon incredibly brutal
and you can decorate it with gothic
stuff so you've got three elements
they're pretty much what the Imperium is
about what hammer 40k is probably my
favorite science fiction franchise so
coming here and learning more of the
story and impact to the bolter has been
a truly amazing experience it is an
object that I feel so familiar with from
the hundreds of miniature versions I've
painted since I was a teen to the video
game adaptations I've willed it via a
keyboard and mouse and yet through the
course of making this video I've learned
so much about the ball gun and after
countless years the sight of one still
triggers a nostalgic memories of the
smell of metal paints if you've never
tried the painting for yourself I
honestly can't recommend it enough
while the Warhammer 40,000 universe is
pretty grim dark I've honestly found
painting to be a calming and wholesome
force for me so if it's something you're
curious about you can head to the Games
Workshop site or your local hobby shop
to pick up a set for yourself and I
would like to extend a thanks to the
Games Workshop team for helping make
this feature happen
thank you so much for watching this
episode of loader if you enjoyed it make
sure you like the video subscribe and
leave your thoughts in the comment
section down below and if you've missed
the previous episodes make sure to go
back and check those out as well